todo comenzó en el barrio de molenbeek
en bruselas donde este francés creció
salar abdeslam regentaba un bar con su
hermano mayor brágimo otro de los
terroristas kamikazes del 13 de
noviembre en su barrio describen al
joven abdeslam como un fiestero y
pequeño traficante de drogas es emol en
bec donde supuestamente conoció
abdelhamid abu el presunto cabecilla de
los ataques de parís
lo que es completamente cierto es que el
13 de noviembre del 2015
salaha abdeslam estaba en parís
se cree que tuvo un rol logístico clave
reservar los escondites y hoteles para
los terroristas alquilar autos y ser él
mismo el décimo miembro de los comandos
salas abdeslam también está acusado de
ayudar a algunos de los atacantes a
moverse por europa incluso viajar a
grecia y hungría para encontrarse con
ellos una pregunta clave en el juicio
será por qué no detonó su cinturón
suicida el 13 de noviembre
temprano al día siguiente de los
atentados se cree que dos cómplices lo
llevaron de regreso a bruselas y
lograron incluso superar los controles
de las policías belga y francesa estuvo
cuatro meses fugitivo hasta que fue
capturado por la policía allí donde todo
había comenzado su vecindario natal de
molenbeek el 18 de marzo del 2016 como
es el único presunto miembro
sobreviviente del grupo que llevó a cabo
los ataques desde su captura está
detenido en régimen de aislamiento su
celda está equipada con cámaras de
vigilancia que funcionan las 24 horas
del día lo que lo convierte en el preso
más vigilado de francia